- Let's talk a little bit
about reproductive success,
which is related to the
number of surviving offspring
that an animal has during its lifetime.
An animal that has more
surviving offspring
has a higher reproductive success.
Now, there's two broad categories
of traits or behaviors
that might drive reproductive success.
One might be behaviors
that increase the chances
of an animal producing offspring.
And we know that most
animals that we study,
not all, but most, reproduce
via sexual reproduction.
To do that,
they need to mate with an
individual of the opposite sex.
And that's why you see
things like peacocks,
where these very elaborate
feathers are a way
of signaling to members
of the opposite sex,
the peahens, that this peacock
here has favorable traits,
is attractive to the
peahen, has good health,
which signals to the peahen
that by reproducing with this peacock,
they're more likely to
have reproductive success.
They'll have healthier offspring,
which are more likely to survive,
which are more likely to
then go on and reproduce.
And then assuming that
animals are able to mate
and able to reproduce,
another behavior that you
will see amongst animals
that will increase the chances
that their offspring will survive,
and then be able to reproduce themselves
is parental care,
or behaviors that protect
offspring from predators.
You see that throughout
the animal kingdom.
Here are some emperor penguins taking care
of their young baby penguin.
Here is a mother grizzly bear
taking care of her bears.
And here the parental care
might be helping them find food,
giving them food, training them,
protecting them from other predators
or from competitors in some way.
And this isn't just amongst
bears, and penguins,
and potentially peacocks and peahens.
It's all in service to,
at least in some level,
reproductive success.